YURI GRINSHTEYN: Service
Level Objectives, or SLOs,
are one of the fundamental
principles of site reliability
engineering.
We use them to
precisely quantify
the reliability target we want
to achieve in our service.
But how do we measure them?
And what do we do in our
SLO monitoring tells us
that there's a problem?
With Service Monitoring we can
track SLOs and error budgets
and quickly respond when our
service is having an issue.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First, let's review the basics.
You may have heard of
SLOs, but what's an SLI?
Let's clearly define
both of those.
Our overall objective here is to
accurately quantify reliability
and measure our user happiness.
The actual thing we'll
use as a proxy for that
is called the Service
Level Indicator, or SLI.
We need to define that
indicator for our service.
An easy place to
start is by using
one of our golden signals.
We'll put the link to the
Monitoring chapter of the SRE
book where those are
explained in the notes below.
You can also watch the excellent
video created by Liz and Seth
that explains this
topic in greater detail.
We'll link to that, too.
Generally, SLIs fall
into two categories.
Request-based SLIs
measure the fraction
of good units of work
against the total.
For example, what percentage of
a request to an HTTP endpoint
were successful on
a given time window?
Window-based SLIs measure the
fraction of time intervals
during which the service meets
some threshold over a given
time window.
Let's use an example.
If we have an app
engine service,
we can use the response
count metric as our SLI.
Specifically, we can
count our good responses
by filtering that metric
for only responses that
return an HTTP 200 and use
the unfiltered value to count
our total responses.
We divide the two to arrive at
the fraction, or ratio of good
to total.
And that's our SLI.
Now let's talk about SLOs.
A Service Level Objective
is the target value
for our SLI measured over time.
It's generally comprised
of three things, the SLI,
a target for the SLI, and a
window over which it's measured
called the compliance period.
So for our simple
HTTP service, we
may set our SLO as 99% of
requests return HTTP 200
for the last 28 days.
Our error budget
then is essentially
the inverse of the SLO.
In this example, we're expecting
that 1% of our requests
will fail every day.
Now that we have
that sorted out,
let's take a look at how we
can use the Service Monitoring
API to create, track,
and alert on our SLOs.
First, we define our SLI
and SLO using a JSON payload
and send it to the
API to create them.
There are four
key elements here.
The good service filter
and total service filter
are how we specify
how we're counting
good and total requests.
The goal is the actual
objective for the SLO,
the target we want to meet.
And the rolling period is
the time window over which
we want to evaluate our SLI.
Once our SLO is created, we can
then create an alerting policy,
using SLO burn rate
as the condition type.
We want to be notified if
our service consumes error
budget at an elevated rate.
In the alerting policy
we specify the threshold,
the percentage of
error budget consumed,
and the look back duration--
the period over which
that consumption can happen.
If our service
experience is an issue,
our alerting policy
will create an incident,
letting us know that our error
budget burn rate is too high.
We then know that our
service quality has degraded
and we should take immediate
action to resolve the issue.
Now that we have Service
Monitoring set up and alerting
for service issues
configured, we
can be much more
confident that we'll
be able to deliver on our
service level objectives
and keep our users happy.
Thanks for joining me today.
That's it for this episode.
This is The Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]